[Applause]
look at you all keeping your chin up huh
let's good for you and welcome to this
week's edition of he did what
what does auto truck judo well I tell
you something he did the impossible he
made going to the airport shittier than
it was this one will be come on we got
news that Muslim ban he instituted a
federal judge knocked that out into a
high yeah so if you missed this I mean
there's so much news this guy creates
but way back after our last show which
resulting a week ago he insisted this
Muslim ban which he called a ban and
then his press secretary Sean Spicer
called the ban and then there were
protests an engine on it was a ban and
then Trump tweeted well you can call it
a ban if you like so they're really on
message and the message is we have no
idea what we're doing but hey
heyyou Muslims don't think you're
special because our president picked a
fight with a lot of people as weak a lot
of finally a president has shown the
balls to stand up to our arch enemy
Australia right he had a cool yet a call
with the Australian Prime Minister
longtime poodle dog ally of America and
he finally said to him you know what I
had five calls today this is the worst
and hung up
well first he said we're building a
wallaby and you're gonna pay for know I
mean I didn't interesting just at a week
he's threatened to invade Iran Mexico
Chicago today today we declared war on
lala land I mean this this can't be
going well I mean it is starting to look
like that our only hope is penis
enlargement surgery really I
oh and no one's seen Milania for like
since the inauguration hey I don't want
to say we have a mad king who has his
wife locked in the tower but it's
literally called Trump Tower I mean
[Applause]
she's like a slovenian rapunzel rapunzel
rapunzel let down your extension so
turning to domestic insanity
Donald Trump okay this week announced
his Supreme Court pick but he did it
like a reality show with an unveiling of
finalists that actually happened then
for Holocaust Remembrance Day the
administration's that it is tight high
time on this day we stopped mentioning
the Jews really other people thought it
was no protected no no we did this on
purpose
why because other people were killed -
yes the Jews have been hogging the
Holocaust fake news
and then it was time to insult black
people so I'm telling you it's the Equal
Opportunity because this was the
beginning of February which is Black
History Month so Trump gathered all the
black people he knows in one room he was
like a kid showing off his Pokemon cards
you know this is amarosa her special
power is fast and it's great he called
it a listening session and he did all
the talking all about himself in the
election and how unfair the news
coverage has been only Trump could take
the occasion of Black History Month and
make it about how he's oppressed
and then he outdid himself really even
him started talking about Frederick
Douglass someone who stood a terrific
job terrific job and is being recognized
by more and more people
where are you Freddy stand up let's
efficacy Fred Douglass tremendous guy
tremendous and then someone called from
Frederick Douglass is dead and trumpet
oh no gang violence and finally to cap
off the week yesterday at the National
Prayer Breakfast the National Prayer
Breakfast he suppresses it open the
proceedings by saying what tremendous
success Celebrity Apprentice was when he
was the host of it but now that it's
Arnold Schwarzenegger it's a total
disaster the ratings went right down the
tubes amen